we always go to vacations when it's
crowded and it costs much more because
that's when the kids are off school so
parents took their kids away from school
either the week before or the week after
it was much cheaper and much nicer
vacation schools didn't like it what did
they do put a fine of 60 pounds of
parents coming late that mistake because
now people instead of saying look it's
bad to do it now they said 60 pounds I'm
going to save a thousand pound by not
going during the crowded time
what are incentives for the people that
are not indoctrinated into understanding
what that is incentives is something
that will make you do a thing that you
wouldn't do otherwise to try to push you
in this direction a common mistake is
that incentive is only money it's
definitely not there are many other
things that could be it could be status
it could be playing computer games not
teaching at class many other things but
in general it's something that will make
you do a thing that otherwise you
wouldn't
what do you think that economists get
most wrong about incentives
it's uh it's a long list but basically
it's a if you read about incentives in
economics it's you see a formula as if
it's physics
right as if you're talking about
particles or atom atoms you know moving
around the the world and that's not the
case we're talking about people
incentives work that part economies got
very much right but we don't always know
how they work simplifying assumptions
that people just you know you give them
more money it's better you you give them
more incentives you're going to get more
of what you want that's just wrong the
main thing that people that economists
Miss I think is that incentives send a
signal when I give you incentive when I
tell you if you'll do X I'll pay you ten
dollars
then you get the ten dollars plus you
get a signal that that's what I want you
to do and then you start thinking why
does we want me to do this is that that
for me is that good for me water is
motives right so you get you start
interpreting this incentives basically
complete a story you have a story in
your mind you look at the world
and once you get incentives it helps you
to create one sort of of a story and
it's kind of like a feedback loop
because for every incentive that I'm
given there is a story about that
incentive what does it mean what do I
know about URI what has URI incentivized
me to do previously what can I infer
about his desires for me moving forward
ongoing story that never ends okay so if
that's
what economists get wrong what's the
missing addition what what gets folded
into the economic view of this which
starts to flesh it out a little bit more
so after trashing my Economist friends
now I can crash my psychologist friends
basically psychologists when they talk
about incentives so you can take the
same class the same um
title of class in my business school one
would be taught by economists that will
be completely mapped completely out of
it's not people it's about machinery and
you can take the same class with
psychologists and other data say that
you you go to work just because you want
fulfillment and all the good stuff that
you get from the work that's also a
mistake right so it's also not the case
it's the the combination of the two is
what you should think about I go to work
because I need to make money and they go
to work because they want to feel better
about myself
and the secret is how you get these
signals to work together right so that's
that that's what I'm trying to do in
this so how to get the the money that
they give you and you need money when
you come to work you you go because you
need the money but how do I make the
payments that I give you such that you
actually feel better about yourself feel
better about going to work or do
whatever the activity I'm interested in
how common is it to have this more
integrated View
it's not common at all so like I said if
you take a class in the business school
you'll take either of the of the
versions there are very few that gives
you both versions I think and that's
that's pretty that's what that's
basically the Gap that I'm trying to
feel over here fascinating okay so
breakdown social signaling and self
signaling for me what's the difference
so when we're talking about signaling
there the first one is quite clear it's
what you know what I want you to think
about me I I do things I dress up I
decide to contribute I decide to do good
things or bad things because I care
about the signals that they send to you
I care what you think about me what you
your listeners my bosses my kids what
they think about me
that's the social signaling and the self
signaling is also surprisingly about
myself so I don't really know how good I
am and when I say Good by the way I
don't mean good in the philosophical
version of it good could be I could be a
mess murderer and good for me would be
that I killed 10 people today right
so why I I don't know how good I am at
whatever my goals are and I look at my
actions and I I learn from it about
myself I can give you a story from there
from the book an example from the book
imagine that you live in a cold place
you see your neighbor walks in the
morning in a cold morning to the recycle
center with a large bag filled with 100
soda cans what are you going to think
about her
she's very altruistic oh my God I can't
believe that she's trudging through the
snow purely to save the planet
perfect that's what she will probably
think about herself as well right
because she's good now imagine
same story but
you live in a place where she get five
cents per soda can the cheese recycling
now she's a ruthless capitalist exactly
or just cheap for five dollars really so
that's the social signaling what you're
going to think about there and there's
also self signaling before that in the
first version she was I'm a good person
I care about the environment I'm
recycling I'm I'm good the second
version I'm cheap do I really want to do
it
so this
this tells us an awful lot more about
folding in status and those signals into
the pure economics of the situation and
also explains about how incentives can
become perturbed
absolutely so you learn a lot to think
from just this simple example because
first of all there are a few things you
get a signal by by the amount in this
case so because it's only five cents you
you deduct that that's not probably not
that important to do if you would get
five dollars per soda can then you'll
start buying soda cans and just recycle
them right so if I'll pay you enough you
think well that's really important it's
good for the world right I want to do it
so the size sends you a signal many many
of the things are sending you signals
and all this so imagine that um I'll go
to for a ski vacation and ask my
assistant to stay over and work on
something that they need to finish over
the weekend
I'll come back on Monday and give him
ten dollars as a thank you gift he'll be
insulted by that right that's if I give
him a chocolate
that cost ten dollars that's less
insulting if I'll give him ten thousand
dollars he'll be very happy
right so it's not just the fact that I'm
paying you so that's how much I'm paying
you if I'll pay you tensor if I'll pay
my assistant ten thousand dollars for
staying over the weekend you'll be
extremely happy
right so the the amount is important in
other cases that you can think about
imagine that I offered to pay you for
sex then no matter how much I'm going to
offer you it's going to be insulting
right because that means
I didn't say that you wouldn't do it
right right I didn't say you wouldn't do
it but you might be insulted that it's
not just your look that I'm after tell
me what chocolate bar it was and then
I'll I'll reconsider it right exactly
what's the difference between the ten
dollars and the chocolate bar
the old world of gifts is really
exciting it's um
we are wasting huge amounts of times and
money on trying to buy gifts that will
send the right signal there is an
amazing
um
episode in Seinfeld that shows this when
Nigeria has to buy Lane a birthday gift
so he and George go to the store and he
says no this is too sexual this is to
whatever too domestic so he really needs
to find because it sends signals but the
gift that I'm saying at the end it gives
her cash and she screams the team what
are you my uncle why what are you doing
right so gifts are really sending
signals and if I'll give you a 10
chocolate bar it's still I'm sending you
a signal that they cared about you I
went to this place I I thought about you
I bought you
um I bought you chocolate now imagine
going to a friends tonight for dinner
and you can bring a bottle of wine you
can be nice and buy a 50 bottle of wine
and give them everyone will be happy
imagine that you'll go and say well I
got stuck at work I had this very boring
podcast with URI and they didn't have
time to buy it but here's fifty dollars
that's going to be very awkward right so
what you give is really signaling
something about you this is why online
card sending websites to me have always
seemed a little bit odd that part of the
part of the purpose of accounting what
even if you get the most insane pop-up
3D sings A pre-recorded message to you
card what are you looking at 15 bucks
maybe 20 bucks absolute top top end and
it'll it'll fly itself there
the the reason that you get a card is
because everyone knows how much of a
mess on it is to do and oh you've had to
you've had to pick up a pen for the
first time in six months since somebody
else's birthday that you cared about and
I get to see your terrible handwriting
and you scream you know it like that's
part of the process and uh saying that
uh now I live abroad I actually do see
the value of this because it's an
absolute nightmare to ship stuff across
the Atlantic that being said did you
watch the Netflix series Pepsi where's
my jet
no but it's a great title so in the
1980s 1990s
Pepsi started releasing Pepsi Points and
if you bought a can maybe you got a
sticker of some kind I think and you
peeled that off and if you collected
enough you can exchange it for a pair of
sunglasses or a leather jacket and it
had a ascending hierarchy of how many
points got you a thing and in the advert
at the very end this kid that the advert
is about turns up at school outside of
his classroom in a Harrier jump Jet and
it says at the bottom
Harrier jumped at one million points
no asterisk no small print no subjective
terms and conditions no this doesn't
exist this is obviously a joke none of
that and this kid watched it looked at
it and a hundred times realized that it
wasn't in there recruited his Rich
friend his father's Rich friend who is a
founder and had way more money than he
needed
started working out how he could can
purchase in bulk all of these Pepsi cans
employ people in different warehouses
distributed around the US in order to be
able to do this they basically worked
out that they were getting a Harrier
jump chat
95 discounted Pro rata uh and they then
began this massive litigation between
this kid and Pepsi and I thought it's
it's a really good documentary if anyone
hasn't watched it on Netflix I highly
recommend that you watch it I will
Okay so we've looked at signals we've
looked at
what it says about ourself what it says
socially what's the problem when it
comes to mixed signals
so I can tell you what's important for
me but then I give you signals that say
something very different right so
remember incentives and signal and I can
tell you that they care about for
example I care about quality I really
want you to do it this well but then I
pay you for quality for quantity
you're not going to invest that much in
quality you're going to think about the
the quantity how much you can do can you
do more than this and you'll neglect the
quality so here's here are a few
examples right so think about
um drivers bus drivers so in Israel we
have this route in which you have bus
drivers that are paid by by the hour you
go on them they draft very nicely
they're very polite everything is great
they take their time on the other hand
we have these mini buses that are paid
per passenger the driver is paid per
passenger they drive like crazy right
because they need to be there on time to
pick up people they start driving before
you sit
right it's really inconvenient they're
less safe all of the bad stuff so the
quality really suffers but they produce
more
now there are lots of stories like that
about small unimportant thing but if you
think about Healthcare in the US that's
a great example where it becomes much
sadder so imagine two doctors you go to
the doctor and you need the you have
back pain
now the doctor looks at you and there
are three options either the doctor says
look she looks at you and she says
that's fine just rest a bit it's going
to be okay or she looks at you and said
sorry you really need this surgery those
are two extreme cases you'll get what
you what you deserve what you need
in the middle in the gray area you'll
have lots of places where yeah you know
one doctor will say that you need a
surgery not enough now imagine that you
live in a place like most of the world
in which the physician is not paid for
surgery per procedure that she's making
she is going to look at it and make a
call decision based on science how she
understands Science Now imagine that on
top of that she's paid
a few thousand dollars for operating on
you
if you think that that's not going to
affect her judgment you are very naive
like she might even not know that that's
what she's doing but she's going to look
at it and say look I I you clearly need
a surgery where if you compare hospitals
in which their physician is or is not
paid for surgery you see a big
difference in this in back surgeries in
C-sections in many other things think
about the sad example
someone goes to the doctor the doctor
tells that person look I'm sorry you're
not going to see next Christmas you are
you're dying from cancer we did the best
we can that's it I can give you another
round of chemo it will prolong your life
by three months but that's not the
quality of life is not going to be high
you're going to suffer or I can send you
on with palliative care and make sure
that you die in a in a nice way right
that's that's one way of saying it now
imagine that this same physician this
same oncologist is paid ten thousand
dollars if you choose to take this round
another round of chemo
now without it's not it's not it is that
this doctor is doing something wrong or
immoral but this doctor might not even
know but it's going to be much more
likely to recommend another round of
chemo
right so that's all of it is about the
quality versus quantity
in my example I'm a I'm judged by
Publications how many papers I publish
research papers I publish my Dean can
decide to pay me per paper
and then the signal that that I hear is
that I need to publish as many papers as
I can
but then the quality is going to suffer
I'm going to publish a lot of papers but
they are not going to be very good
right so all of this is the quantity
versus quality which is
I'll always tell you the hospital will
always tell the surgeon look you care
about the patient that's number one
priority the hospital we never talk will
never tell you look your goal is to
maximize the profits per patient
but when they give the incentives that's
a signal that the incentive sent so
that's the mixed signal part of it and
it's not as you said it's not as if the
surgeon is really even capable of
removing that signal from their own mind
or that incentive sorry from their own
mind so you go okay even if you were
fully aware even if there's a surgeon
who works in America who's listening to
this podcast right now who gets
incentivized to be the oncologist that
gets another round of chemo how on Earth
are you supposed to do the expected
value calculation of well I understand
that deep down there is an amount of me
that
will lean toward wanting to be paid and
I'll have to Discount appropriately and
you know it's impossible
it's impossible and we have research
showing this so we have it's not with
surgeons we don't play around with with
people's lives but we do play around
with money so we get people to the lab
we tell them their ears option a option
b you need to recommend it to someone
else
most of them choose to recommend option
A in this case we bring another group we
tell them here's option A here's option
b
you need to recommend one of them by the
way if you recommend option b you'll get
a dollar
now most of them recommend option b now
you can say either they are cynical and
they just lie or the convince them like
themselves like the surgeon or the
oncologist that you just mentioned that
that's actually better for the for the
other person so we have a third group in
which we tell them ears option A Year's
option b choose one of them don't tell
me which one do you think is better
after they choose we tell them oh by the
way if you recommend option b we'll give
you a dollar
same incentive as before but first these
people had to make their judgment and
only then they learn about the
incentives now most of them again
recommend a right which shows that in
the second option the one in which they
learned about the incentives as they
learned about the options they really
changed the way they think about it they
self-deceive themselves to think that b
is better I think that very much of that
is going on in the mind of Physicians or
financial advisors any people mechanics
Maybe
yeah that's the uh was it fiduciary
agreement that a lot of accountants and
investment advisors have that the
fiduciary uh whatever it is consent uh
forces them to at least try and have the
clients issues in mind speaking of you
mentioned uh buses and minibuses didn't
you look at something to do with uh
incentives for Uber drivers
yes so the you mentioned we talked about
the buses and minibuses right so how do
you get incentives that will give you
money per passengers so you'll actually
have reason not to sit and drink coffee
and but rather to think about where am I
going to have more passengers I'm going
to make more money while not making you
reduce the quality drive very fast dirty
car and all this and I think that the
ride sharing like uber Lyft found a very
smart way of doing this by giving Direct
by creating the rating system so now
after a ride if you drive
too fast too aggressively your car will
be dirty or something like that I will
give you one star that's going to be bad
for you so you really care about your
ratings so now on top of the incentive
to be fast it also give you incentives
to be good and that actually works and
interestingly it doesn't cost the
company anything to create this
incentive scheme right so you really
create something that cost you nothing
and was really important now my
experience I don't know about yours
whenever I still use taxes which is not
a lot it's always Less Pleasant than the
Uber experience correct Uber is Uber is
always cleaner the driver is more polite
everything is nicer
is incentivized yes yeah without money
without any cost yes yes one thing that
I learned that was interesting about
Uber is the
drivers
do not get paid more if the journey ends
up being detoured if it takes longer if
it gets stuck in traffic and I thought
it's a little bit brutal for the drivers
but it's very good for the rider that if
you do hit uh un uh realized challenge
of some kind that it is still you're not
going to be paid uh you're not going to
be charged anymore and it's not as if
the you know the old will take you
around the houses the long route in
order to ramp up the extra amount of
money it stops that from happening so
this part is clearly great right so they
really have the incentive to get you
from where they pick you up to the drop
place as fast as possible I actually
think that they are underpaid
okay how do I know that apart from the
fact that I know how much you know they
tell me how much they make and they
worked a bit with Uber apart from that I
know that it takes too long to get an
Uber where I live so pre-pandemic it
used to be five minutes now it's off in
15 minutes 15 minutes means that they
are not paid enough if they would have
been paid more I would prefer you know
I'm privileged I have the money so
that's true it's not my daughter would
not prefer it
but uh but still I think that just from
from the quality of service how long it
takes I would prefer that they will make
20 more and I'll get them within five
minutes instead of 15 minutes
right so and and sometimes for example
it takes them 10 minutes to get here so
they drive for 10 minutes and then they
take me from my home to the university
which they get eight dollars
that's kind of I think that that's bad
we need I I really I feel good when I
pay a fair wage to the people that me
too uh I use Uber I don't have a car in
America so I've been since I moved here
about a year ago I've been absolutely
hammering you I must have done hundreds
hundreds and hundreds of Journeys just
in the last year and uh yeah I I would
agree uh it'll be interesting to see
what happens with Uber over the next few
years okay so one of the other mixed
signals that you talk about is
encouraging Innovation but punishing
failure what would be an example of that
right right so you always tell people
you know you tell your worker you don't
tell them look do exactly the same and
don't innovate just do small changes
think about my world right I can write
lots of papers by changing a small
parameter in something that someone else
did those are going to be really boring
bad papers or I can take a risk I can
think about something completely
different
and by taking the risk basically what
I'm saying is the time increasing the
variance right so there is a chance that
it will be much better but there's also
a chance that it will be much worse now
if I work for you and you look at me you
see that I tried something and they
failed and as a result you fire me or
don't give me a bonus so whatever way
you punish me why would I take this risk
right why would I go and try something
new if I know that it that it has risk
so the right thing to do it to to to
encourage Innovation is to tell you look
go ahead try it if it doesn't work tell
me fast don't drag it because if I know
that you're going to punch me I'm going
to still you know throw good money after
the bad money and try to make it work
force it to work no just whenever
whenever I see that it doesn't work just
kill it that's fine and then do this
debrief you know what happened
why did it happen now if you find out
that it happened because I slept until
noon and then drank lots of coffee then
fire me then punish me but if you see
look it was a good idea the intuition
was solid you tried it turns out it
didn't work
let's learn from it from the future I'll
know to make the same mistake into in
the future and move on to the next thing
that's the right way to do I run
experiments for living right that's
that's my research
doing incentives for 25 30 years very
often I have an idea I go to the
experiment I test it and the students do
something else than what I expect so I
get mad at the students but I try to
learn from it right Why didn't it it
works sometimes it's more interesting if
your intuition didn't work you learned
something
much more interesting stuff and
sometimes it's not but the point is to
to incentivize really a failure as well
because if the failure happened because
your intuition was wrong but still was
solid
just don't punish for that Rory
Sutherland has a story where he always
talks about the fact that nobody ever
got fired for hiring Accenture and his
point being that if you have a a
reliable but boring Pursuit
no one ever gets in trouble for that
whereas if you say look this is
something we're not going to use the
blueprint we're going to actually try
and go out there and do something that
may have a an upside of 100x but a
slightly greater downside as opposed to
just iterating on what we've done before
and he says that this is one of the
reasons why the consultancy model a lot
of advertising is very safe very boring
you know it's handled by accountants uh
and economists rather than by creatives
and artists right right I think that
he's absolutely right now you can think
about the world in which you don't you
you cannot allow for the downside risk
right so imagine that you know I don't
want my physician to take risks on my uh
on me right in some cases but then your
message should be look I want you to
play it safe
creativity is important in other places
be go and paint in your garage after
that after work but here it's really
important that's fine that's a message
and then be go with it but what I'm
saying is don't tell them be creative
but then like you said if if it doesn't
work punish them that's that's the mixed
signal right so if you want creativity
don't punish if you don't want
creativity which is also fine tell them
that that's not what you're looking for
in this job
what was that story about the Coke
vending machine thermometer
I love this story so the CEO of
Coca-Cola another probably either
engineer or economist
without social skills
that he can put a thermometer there is a
thermometer at the vending machine that
can tell them whether let's say let's
divide it to hot and cold days
it took probably econ 101 it talks about
price discrimination and said look on a
call day we'll charge them a dollar and
I hope they will charge 1.50 because
they're willing to pay more that's what
airlines do that's what hotels do it's
it's it's fine right so if it's busy you
take more
people of course got peace to them they
said why are you trying to take
advantage of us when you thought that's
you know that's not nice and the right
way to to do it would have been
making the regular price dollar fifty
and on a cold day we'll give you a
discount it's only a dollar right so
that that's really great
right that that way you know you're nice
to me actually when you can you're nice
to me AMC last month AMC came up with a
similar program
they decided that AMC Theaters they
decided that they they're going to
charge different prices for different
seats right if you want to sit in the
middle of the theater you'll pay extra
you'll pay they call it premium seats
and you'll pay extra again lots of
pushbacks it's not enough that we pay so
much for the tickets that we pay so much
for the Pokemon now you also want you
want us to pay much more for the middle
six you know fu
the way they should have said it is and
then they try to say well inflation
whatever they should have started with
inflation look it cost us more we have
to pay more for labor everything cost us
more we have to raise prices we are
really sorry for this that's not what we
want we want everyone to be able to go
and because of that we're going to give
discount for the first row and for the
site so everyone can still come over and
and use it right so that's the exactly
the same incentives but very different
story
think about the coming back from the
pandemic a friend of mine told me a
story a couple of days ago
they they went they they worked remotely
and then they decided to go back to
three days a week in the in the office
and their employees were really upset
with them they looked at it as
punishment
and what you said is that the right
thing to do after listening to these two
examples she said the right thing to do
was to say look look
sorry or not sorry the pandemic is over
we are back to five days a week however
because you were so good
and so responsible we're going to let
you work from home for two days
that's exactly the same story but it's
not we're punishing You by bringing you
up to to the office for three days but
we're rewarding you by giving you two
days to work from home
right so this there is a story out there
our brain completes the story
and the incentives can really change the
way we look at the story
this feels like
uh anchoring bias is is playing a
massive role here anchoring buyers and
expectations are playing doing a lot of
the heavy lifting
and Kareem framing all of the good stuff
that we know from behavioral economics
and Behavioral Science in general works
over here the The Twist is that now it's
done by incentives right so it's not
just the story it's also it's done by
the incentive you give it as an
incentive to people and
that's important to understand that
incentive tell a story and if you
control it you're going to do better
if that's the case how is it that
Peloton saw an increase in sales when
they put the price up
so pattern is a great example so the CEO
wrote that when they started they
charged a thousand dollar for the bike
and no one wanted to buy it because they
decided that it's probably not a good
they concluded it is probably not a
great bike if it cost
so little
again tells you something about the
people that think that a thousand dollar
per bike is little but that's what he
said double the price two thousand
dollars a bit more than that if I
remember correctly everyone said wow
that must be a great bike and moved in
right imagine uh back to to the one
example you go to usually you buy 20
wine
now you're celebrating something you're
celebrating birthday tonight you're
going to the store of say tonight I'm
going to today I'm going to buy a 50
bottle of wine why because we have this
price equals quality in our brain which
is true in many cases if you want to buy
a laptop with more memory it's going to
cost you more you want to buy a Tesla
with longer range you're going to pay
more but in some cases this is just in
your brain and you need to know where to
I'll never forget one of the first
first ever times I sat down at as level
business when I was 16 or 17 and they
were explaining about the fact that uh
Nike's shoe range and you have the
lowest one which is 30 pounds and then
50 pounds and then 70 pounds and all the
way up to you know 250 pounds and this
is this has got all of the fanciest
pieces of kit but if you look at the
difference in terms of the tech that
goes into 250 and goes into 150 which
might be the next closest you're not
looking at very much it's a apart from
signaling I've got the most expensive
pair of shoes they're always going to
look different you're always going to be
able to tell that they'll look different
especially at the bottom end and at the
top end maybe you'll be able to tell I
want right so you have you have your
people that you really care about them
being able to tell right so there is a
group of people that look at the shoe
and say look this is so my wife 150
pound person right I I wear a 50
sneakers right and but my wife sometimes
tells me look look at this uh white
tennis shoes those are 200 150 sometimes
a thousand dollar shoes right so
absolutely yeah and the reason the
signal for the right people precisely so
that's the first part but the second
part and I I remember thinking well look
if we just take a uh utilitarian
amount of shoe per pound spent equation
uh and and try and try and equate that
back why why does anybody including
myself why am I seduced by the shoes at
the top and there is this sort of
signaling thing that goes on but the
other reason is that if you look at the
area under the curve under the price
curve there are people out there who
either simply want the absolute best
because that's what they want or have
250 or 300 or 500 or a thousand bucks to
spend on a pair of shoes and if there is
one that is within that bracket that's
the pair of shoes that they're going to
get now if the best pair of shoes
happens to be 150 dollars
they're going to buy that pair so why
not just continue ratcheting up the
scene features these shoes are Bluetooth
enabled these shoes will correct your
gluten intolerance these shoes will do
whatever like
um we'll write your papers precisely
correct well that would be great for you
um yeah that you just might as well
continue to ratchet it up capture as
much area under the curve of that
difference so think about wine you go to
a wine store you can buy wine from five
dollar bottle up to fifty thousand
dollars
right and you know I drank some of the
more expensive wines because someone
else was buying it I I couldn't tell the
difference I love wine I drink a lot
give me the 20 a good 20 bottle of wine
I'm extremely happy with that very but
what you said about having very
expensive ones in many restaurants you
have you know you go to a restaurant not
a very fancy restaurant and you look at
the wine menu there is a five thousand
dollar bottle of wine over there and
then you ask the the the waiter did
anyone ever ordered it yeah they
probably don't even have the wine but
that gives you that sent you a signal
look this is this is a serious
restaurant because they have this very
expensive wine probably the same goes
with the sneakers right so if this
company can actually manufacture a
thousand dollar
pair of shoes they must be doing
something really good they must be
really high quality even if no one buys
them
that sends a signal that they're really
good and some people will actually buy
them for the reasons that you mentioned
also by pushing the top end price
further up what you're doing is
relatively making the mid-range products
seem cheaper right we're looking at
anchoring anchoring again at the top
okay okay so you've got um long-term
goals and short-term results as another
mixed signal that often happens what's
going on there so there is this saying
that we all know by a politician we all
know what's the right thing to do we
just don't know how to get elected with
it
right so think about politicians think
about I live in California think about
my Governor that understands that
building a train from San Diego to San
Francisco a fast train is really
important so if I want to go from San
Diego to even to La it's like a
three-hour trip it's it's just
impossible it's not it's not a viable
option and say that our governor will
decide yes I'm going to invest in this
it's going to cost you know 50 billion
dollars but we're going to put the money
in it and we're going to do it he'll
have to invest a lot now
and the benefit will be 20 years in the
future
you'll be long gone you will probably
not get reelected because he diverted
funds from roads today can fix the
bridge next to my house I'll just say
wow he's a good governor
if you invest in something that I don't
see I will not understand it right
so
why would they invest in the loan Grant
if the short run is so
um so much more rewarding in terms of
getting reelected think about the CEO
that the board tells them look we care
about the long Grant we want to be
successful in the long run this company
please you know but then judge the CEO
based on
the quarterly earnings
quarterly performance what is the CEO
going to do imagine that the computer
system whatever the network really needs
upgrading so the CEO can decide to
invest a lot in it in the coming two
quarters and then it's going to get huge
benefits in the future but
the next two quarters are going to look
really bad really poorly in terms of
profits and that CEO will probably be
fired or be will not get the bonus or
whatever right so we tell them we tell
the people that work for us like the
governor or the CEO that look we really
want you to think about the long run but
then we we give them incentives to do
the short run and that's that's a big
problem now there's not always a good
solution so the solution for the
governor would be a dictatorship right
but I don't want to live in a
dictatorship right so I kind of like the
the democratic system in which they need
to report back to us so you don't always
have a solution for that but
we try to we should try at least
if I had a company and they needed to
elect to see I would tell that person
look
I really care about the loan Grant I'm
going to let you do this for two years
and just run with it I'm going to to sit
and watch you hopefully you'll do well
I'll try to find the person that they
can really trust and just let them run
with it I would not look at the short
run performance
I wonder whether uh tenured professors
have the same sort of sense now one of
the problems that you have obviously if
you lock somebody in and you guarantee
them
an amount of time that they're going to
stay employed or supported by you that
means that they can drag their feet that
then creates another challenge that you
have which is completely disagree tenure
is the best thing that God ever created
you sounds like you might have some
Progressive incentives here maybe maybe
maybe so it's uh
look we first of all we are tortured for
for many years until we get tenure right
so that's that part is is there and you
try to really when we decide whether to
give someone a tenure we really try to
figure out did we get this person
addicted to to doing research to doing
his or her job
right if we didn't get them addicted
then the second will tenure them
they can just go I need to teach three
weekends a year I can be in the
Caribbean for the rest of the time no
one can do anything unless I'll do you
know something horrible I'll say the you
know racist things or something like
that I will I will keep my job
yet I'm I'm working very hard right
because I really enjoy it and so that's
part of what I said at the beginning
that I'm I'm doing it because I'm
getting paid but I could have worked
much less and still get the same amount
of money I enjoy it right I want to
convince people to buy my book I'm here
trying to to do that right so we are
intrinsically motivated so that's the
but that's not always working right
sometimes you tenure people and they
just quit see lots of them you call them
Deadwood in the
in our faculty and you see this and it's
very hard to do now I think that the
main reason for tenure in with you know
academic faculty was the freedom of
speech because now I can really say
whatever I think again within reason I
cannot say racist things I cannot say
some other stuff but I can I can say
radical opinions that maybe my
University doesn't like it but and many
other people will not like it but I can
still express it and that that seems to
be really important and you can pursue
Innovation you can focus on the long
term etc etc yeah I don't uh
I don't disagree it's um it's very
interesting I didn't really know what
Tanya was until I started the show I
haven't
um involved myself in the inner workings
of how employment of professors at
universities actually uh goes on all
that much and so given
what we're trying to do there is
um
incentivize good behavior why is it that
fines are so ineffective at
incentivizing against unwanted Behavior
just to finish the previous one exactly
what you said the longer I can invest in
the book I talk about a female genital
mutilation project that we're trying to
do we're working on it for six years
it's going to take many years until it's
ready I can do it because I don't have
to worry about the short run let's talk
about let's talk more about that I want
to I want to talk about this female
genital mutilation thing how are you how
are you trying to uh change the
incentives of these places where it's a
common practice
when you go to Africa there are many
places so tens of millions if not more
than that of young women that go through
this female genital genital mutilation
which is a horrible horrible procedure
we focus on them as I try because over
there as far as we know the data is not
clear but the vast majority of girls
around the age of 10 to 12 go through
this procedure now
we might say that oh again these
Americans come and try to change the
behavior of the the culture of uh people
etc etc all the good stuff that was done
way too often in the past this case is
not the same because
people who understand what they're
talking about say that it's worse than
rape what happens over there right so
it's not something that if it was raping
10 year old girls no one would say well
it's part of the culture we should allow
it right FGM is worse than that by many
cases so uh the question is why does it
happen so we looked at it and try to
understand why does it happen it turns
out that to a great extent it happens
for economic reasons because the girl
after she went she goes through this FGM
her value in the marriage Market is much
higher and that's you know it's a very
patriarchal society
basically the value of a woman is
measured in the number of cows how many
cars you're going to get for is it 10
cows or 15 cows or whatever and the
value of the girl for the for her family
is going to be higher if she's going
through this
through this procedure and she'll be
able to find a better husband so that's
why it happens
and why because she can be part of this
of the over the group of women over
there if she's not and everyone all
the other girls are then women later on
they still treat her like a baby they
she'll be outcast to the greatest have
you considered the
motives the culturally adaptive reasons
why this would have first come about I'm
gonna throw my bro science evolutionary
psychologist hat on here and guess that
maybe one of the reasons why you know
speaking as a Westerner who quite enjoys
it when the girls that you have sex with
most of my friends want the other their
partner to enjoy it I'm going to guess
that this is because if the incentive
for individual women to have sex gets
dropped through the floor Chastity is
something that you can expect much more
highly is that what it seems to be
everything you said it has few layers
but first of all according to people who
understand I'm not an anthropologist I'm
not an historian but apparently the men
used to go for a year to to fight or
something they come back find their wife
pregnant they wanted to prevent this now
interestingly what you said about sex
you asked the young men that needs to
decide who they're going to marry do you
want your wife to enjoy sex they all say
yes we want it exactly like you said we
want her to enjoy as much as we do
but then what are you who are you going
to marry well I'm going to marry a woman
that went through this procedure because
then she'll be a better wife in a sense
their value is a wife right so it's it's
really complicated right but it but it's
all about the economics of it now what
we came up with is how can we create an
alternative economic institution that
will compensate for this for the loss of
of value of the woman in the in the
marriage Market what we found is that
they really want the girls to go to high
school high school is
um
is far away it costs a lot of money
think about college for us it's really
it's a boarding school that costs lots
of money if the girl goes there for high
school comes back when she is 18 then
her values much much higher already she
doesn't need to go through FGM she is
already an independent woman she can be
a teacher or nurse or whatever
she's really going to do well but the
parents don't have money to send her out
but we said look we're going to to have
nurses check
validate that they are not uh they did
they didn't perform this horrible
procedure on them if you didn't we're
going to pay for high school as long as
she is uncut we're going to pay for high
school and we think that that's going to
be a very strong motivation for the
parents again because of the economic
aspects of this and hopefully you won't
have to do it forever because once
you'll have enough women that will not
be cut the peer pressure will switch
from oh you're not cut you're a baby we
don't have to consider it all to or your
cut that's unfortunate
yes
also that would mean that the women who
are cut are also most likely to be
uneducated which is a signal that women
would not want to be associated with
this is something it's a again neither
of us uh educated fully educated
anthropologists or evolutionary
psychologists but the
knife edge that different cultural
Technologies uh the way that
the status of different types of
behavior
um are viewed in society to me seems
It's So I mean you know we're talking
about here a relatively small
intervention to stop an incredibly
heavily ingrained piece of of culture
and it's just I find it so interesting
how fine the line is between those two
things and they have lots of other
problems that over there I can see the
problem of people with us changing the
culture because they have so a girl is
getting married at 14 with a 30 year old
man
and start having kids and they have lots
and lots of kids now pre-antibiotics
about half of the kids died so it was
manageable now they have too many kids
in the sense that the resources that
they have cannot support them
right so in terms of uh planning it's
much harder to do and they they have
serious problems with that as well right
so like you said the very simple thing
very simple incentive very simple change
in what you do can really have a huge
impact on the society
given that you're uh not quite the uh
fully robotic behavioral economics
professor but probably are not used to
having such a fundamentally
benevolent impact on a culture with the
work that you do how um how does it feel
personally Crossing into a you know
pretty much a universal good being able
to utilize what you've learned in your
theory to you really make a a pretty
important change to the world here how
does that feel for you
so that's what happens with age you
think right so as a young man I wanted
to publish as many papers become famous
be successful whatever now when you get
older you start to think about again how
can I use it to to Really impact the
world so I work with companies but
that's usually not doing good to the
world right so I help companies make
more money that's not
come on that's that's not creating value
to the world that's creating value to
the company and and to me and then you
can think about few things that are like
this that you know if I can help these
girls right if I can help if I can save
one girl from going through this that's
already I'll die much happier right and
clearly if we can have more and and you
can think about other
um other things that we try to do so I
mentioned the oncologist we're trying to
do end of life kind of um
planning to help people plan better to
the end of life and and this kind of
things and I I find it much more
exciting than running another lab
experiment about some negotiation game
that I still find interesting but
that's less exciting like you said
you've become an ascended individual a
patriarch who is trying to bestow his
insights on the world
um
I think that you could grow it out I
think it would look well
what about the uh fines
um in terms of stopping unwanted
Behavior what's the problems there
and the problem is with your perception
I think you're wrong so fines all we
know about fines comes from really silly
experiments
in which you know they first of all you
cannot come to my lab and live with less
money than you came in
so I can't really give you a fine in my
lab and much of what we say exactly what
you said is the perception in Psychology
and I think that it's wrong that small
that fines are don't work well small
fine don't work so I have this uh this
study about daycares so our girls used
to go to a daycare in um my wife and I
have lived in a suburb of Tel Aviv and
we needed to pick them up by 4 pm in the
in the afternoon
we used to go to Tel Aviv to have lunch
then one day there was traffic I drove
like crazy in order to be there by 4 pm
because you don't pick up your kids too
late then the principal decided that
she'll put a three dollar fine if you
come more than 10 minutes late again we
were in Tel Aviv again traffic this time
I didn't drive like crazy because I'm
not going to risk my life for three
dollars it doesn't make any sense right
so the small fine over here did change
the perception and by the way we found
when Miranda experiment we found that
indeed many people came late more people
came right and it's not because they
thought about it as a babysitting system
uh way you know I'm paying for
babysitter because when we remove the
fine after a while they kept coming late
so what happens what we think happened
it's otherwise you can die what we think
is that before that you didn't know how
bad it is to come late
now we told you that it's three dollars
bad
right if it's only if it's that it
cannot be important now and you can
never remove that anchor exactly this
knowledge once I once I learned it you
can take it now if in some places in the
US it's ten dollar per minute then then
you'll think about it a friend of mine
told me that in Paris there is a place
where if you're late they take your kid
to the police station and you have to
pick up your kid from the police station
that's that's big
wow yeah and you've got the social
impact of that you've got increased
inconvenience so I remember so it's not
that fines don't work it's small fines
that don't work interesting okay now I
remember learning about
Estonian speed traps have you heard of
these no so in Estonia
they have
um
police by the side of the road
and what they do is they'll ping you if
you're going over the speed limit
they'll catch up they'll take you to the
side of the road and you'll have the
choice between I think it's a really
really high fine I think it's
350 Euros maybe or you can stay by the
side of the road for 30 minutes
ah nice and I thought that was a really
interesting way or you know most people
that are going to be pulled over by the
Estonian police
are not making 700 euros an hour
right right but there are people for
whom I'm on my way to pick my kids up
from Nursery we have a wedding we're
getting to we're making a flight we're
doing whatever and it just really makes
people I think question the time and the
the money element uh in a it's much more
interlinked I thought that was a very
smart way to to do it I would put both
so why not pay 350 and wait 30 minutes
some people some people are rich enough
some people are rich enough that they
don't care about the money
some people don't care about being right
well let's think about it this way if
you do do that what you are optimizing
for are people who are both time rich
and money Rich exactly exactly so that's
equalizing you know everyone is going to
suffer one way that they did it in many
places is this preventive driving so if
you you should they catch you get a
ticket you have to go to this school
right that's just that's pure punishment
you don't really learn anything over
there but it's it's very effective
punishment so now I think you can do it
online but in the past you really had to
go there I was fortunate enough not to
go there but my friends who did said
that it was like three afternoons real
punishment so there is a everybody in
the UK will be aware of the speed
awareness course which is what you're
talking about so uh in the UK you're
allowed at 10 over the speed limit uh
that was originally introduced because
analog speedometers had a 10 tolerance
where the car may be sufficiently
inaccurate the fact that that's been
Legacy grandfathered in in a world with
digital speedometers that are probably
accurate to you know 0.1 of a mile per
hour Etc is still hilarious but
um and then I think it's the next 10
over that
if you are in that bracket you have the
choice between a hundred pounds fine and
three points on your license if you hit
12 then you lose your license or you can
go and do a speed awareness course the
speed awareness course is a morning or
an afternoon with an incredibly grumpy
gentleman stood at the front asking you
I've I've been so this is personally
relevant to me
um
the most banal boring questions wagging
his finger saying you are driving down
the street how can you tell if you're
going too quickly like just oh my God
it's torture however uh you're only
allowed even one of those I think once
per two year period so you only even get
one of those Grace periods so there's
this sort of ascending punishment ladder
that you can go through and if you use
that you lose one of your lives uh but
honestly I think that the
you know I I have a number of friends
who are regularly in and out of points
on their license I've only ever got
pinged by this once either through my
great driving or through fortune or
whatever however
how the speed awareness course stuck in
my mind I can remember the the classroom
that we sat in I can remember how boring
the tapes were I can remember the effort
of having to drive there on the more I
can remember everything about it right
that's a very very strong interest
incentive so you see fines do work you
just need to find the right fine what
whatever will make you drive carefully
after that whatever Hurts the Most
talking about cars what was that online
car shop Edmonds right Edmonds yes
so that's actually interesting Edmonds
is a great company I worked with him
there from LA and what they do is give
you information about cars so you want
to buy a car you go there you check a
Toyota Corolla from
you know a new Toyota Corolla and you
you learn about it and then when you
want to buy when you're ready to buy
they have ads from local dealerships you
put in your zip code and they know where
you are they offer you
deals now if you buy through them
so if you click on on the link over
there and you end up buying the car they
that's of course good for them because
then the dealerships are going to pay
them more for for advertising now what
they did is gave you say say that you
bought a twenty thousand dollar card
they gave you 500 discount if you if you
clicked on admins and went over there
now 500 is a lot of money but not when
you compare it to twenty thousand
dollars so we know from previous
research old research from the 70s and
80s that imagine that you're going to
buy a mouse for your computer right
you'll go to the to the store and the
guy will tell you it's fifty dollars but
if you'll walk 10 minutes there is
another store they have it 50 off you
get 25 off most of us will go many of us
will go I imagine that you buy a
computer and then you also buy this this
you pay two thousand dollars for the for
the computer and you also want is one of
the accessories a mouse
and now the the guy will tell you can
either pay 2050 over here or you can go
and buy it over there and pay 2025 over
there you say well it's not right so you
compare it to the deal itself
so 500 itself didn't it worked but not
as good as you would imagine
what we thought is something that is
called mental accounting mental
accounting is basically what you care
about what what is it that you really
care not all money is created equal and
what we thought about is gas money right
so if I give you a credit card for 500
that you can spend on buying gas
now you can imagine yourself standing in
the gas station and you know fueling
your car and 500 is a lot of money you
can feel it for a long time this is
something that you really don't like to
do and now you get it for free
that has much longer impact the same
amount of money actually we found in our
experiment that we did with them the 200
in gas money were more effective than
500 cash
now if I'll ask you what do you prefer
that I'll give you 500 in cash or 200
gas money of course you'll choose the
500 but because it was separate it was
different people did not look at it as
part of the deal they said oh I'm going
to get this that's great and that was
more effective
and that's again about the story that
you tell yourself
what it means in order to get this money
another car that you looked at the
Toyota Prius what was interesting about
that
so in their late 90s early 2000 both
Honda and Toyota came up with the hybrid
cars
and fortunately for them those were
really bad cars why why fortunately so
today if you buy a Prius it's a
competitive car it's it's a very good
car
back then they were bad and that was
great because if you wanted to sing now
look I'm I'm a good guy I care about the
environment
you should buy a hybrid car because for
the same amount of money you could have
bought a much better car the only reason
that you would buy some the Prius or the
whatever the alternative we'll get to it
in a second by Honda is because you care
about the environment that's why you buy
hybrid cars so that's great right and
that's that's very good and that's why
people were actually attracted to it I
think to a great extent but then Honda
made the decision that was probably
dictated by the engineers who said look
do it based on the Honda Civic the parts
are going to be the same everything is
going to be much easier Toyota took a
very different approach they said let's
redesign the car completely
now when you see a previous you know
that you see a hybrid car I imagine that
you drive into the parking lot with your
not so great car
in one case there is a small plan at the
back at the back saying hybrid car
that's the Honda example in that case
everyone sees it from distance look
oh you're a great guy you're driving
this uh this hybrid car and according to
every people all the people that
understand that's why Toyota won the the
market because they produce a bad car
and it was clear to everyone that you're
driving a bad car so you're a good guy
exactly and something important to to to
note over here is that the importance
that not all incentives are good for
everyone
right so in this case we're talking
about people who care about the
environment if you think about the guys
that drive pickup trucks
those incentives will mean nothing to
them right you really have to Target
when I tell when I say that you send a
signal and you you complete the story
you need to think about the people that
you care about it might be if if you
want to sell a hybrid car don't create
signals that talk to the
to the pickup and drivers those are not
the freedom of the open road and Loud
country music yeah they're right exactly
exactly whatever they care about
give them and whatever incentives these
people care about so and that's true but
in general when I think we will
when you design incentives you really
think about the signal that you send and
you really think need to think about it
within the culture that you're talking
about so it could be a culture like uh
we we use you know maybe the US you can
make it more competitive in Japan
competitive incentives are not good but
even within San Diego it could be taxi
drivers versus teachers versus lawyers
versus
doctors everyone will have a different
culture and they'll care about different
things and you need to to adjust your
story and very often I I wouldn't know
it the people that are there they should
know what what is it that people like
that care about it's very culturally
dependent in that case
the uh the advertising company the
behavioral economists that are working
whoever it is
there is still an incredibly important
role for you to couch whatever the deal
is whatever the incentives are within
understanding the incredibly
inter-complex played structure of all of
the different ways that status and
stories and Framing and anchoring and so
on and so forth happens not only within
the country not only within this
particular demographic but within this
region within that cohort Etc you
mentioned the shoes don't ask me about
shoes I really have the same shoe I buy
five of them every year fifty dollars
great shoes don't ask me about the
sneakers which costs a thousand dollars
well you can ask me I can I can guide
you through what you need to learn in
order to in order to understand it there
are some rules that I can tell you but
the the details of this you really need
to figure out yourself you need to find
people that care about it don't ask me
about Tick Tock I I heard about it I I
don't know exactly what it is right so
it's really you need to find the people
that understand what you're talking
about
is a bad incentive worse than no
incentive at all then
yes no question about that because bad
incentives will like you asked me at the
beginning the first question was what's
incentive incentive will take you in the
direction that I want you to go that
incentives will take you away from the
direction they want to
so think about the daycare example
instead of getting parents to come late
less time we got parents coming late
more times
right and you wanted maybe a UK example
so in Wales they had something similar
and they parents will really identify
with this example we always go to
vacations during spring break side when
it's crowded and it costs much more
because that's when the kids are off
school
so parents took their kids away from
school either the week before the week
after it was much cheaper and much nicer
vacation schools didn't like it what did
they do put a fine of 60 pounds of
parents coming late right
that mistake because now people instead
of saying look it's bad to do it now
they said 60 pounds I'm going to save a
thousand pound by not going during the
crowded timing
so
what was that uh there's that story
about is it cobras in India
yes so that story is a bit fishy but
there is a similar story that I think is
more grounded in in reality and that's
by the way one of my favorite pastime is
to look at the incentives gun bed I call
it stakes and mistakes
so the French came to
to annoy Vietnam today and they wanted
to have sewage because that's what
French people wanted to do with sewage
came you know they wanted toilet with
sewage came rats rats are not nice and
they decided to kill them and someone
really smart came up with the with
incentive scheme instead of sending my
own people hiring people to do that
let's give the people power to the
people so they decided to give say one
cent per rat tail
per person right so if you bring a rat
tail to the city you'll get 10 cents or
one cent whatever whatever it was so you
had this poor guy the city hall that
counted rat tails great great example
what can go wrong right that's that's
that's a good uh we want you to get rid
of them Well turns out first of all that
you started seeing a tail less rats
running around the city because why
would I kill the rat if they we want to
have more of them we want to have more
babies people started to farm them so
you had rat Farms people started
bringing Rats from other places right so
you need to be careful
and the idea was good the implementation
was less good
you ask me our bed incentives worse than
no incentive yes especially when related
to rat tails
um yes what about using incentives to
identify problems that seems like a a a
pretty big opportunity
right so in many cases we think that we
know what's going on but we don't have
this paper with my friends in which we
we looked at the pizza testing Pisa is
something that is done by oecd they in
Brussels they look at many places many
countries and try to have the same test
to everyone and try to evaluate who's
best in math for example turns out that
the US invests lots of money per student
and is ranked somewhere in the mid 30s
not doing very well
and China for example Shanghai was
number one
now the question why and the
interpretation by everyone is look it's
because because of the ability we need
to learn from the Chinese so Finland for
example is ranked very high we need to
go there and try to understand what
they're doing better than us so the
assumption is always that the kids are
doing better that basically what you
measure is the ability in the in doing
math for example
now the way the test is done is they
take a bunch of 15 year old kids put
them in the room for three hours tell
them look answer these questions as best
as you can you'll never know the outcome
your parents will never know your
teachers the school no one will know
some accountant in Brussels will know
but it's really important that you'll
work on it I don't know if you can
relate to your 15 year old self
I you know I I can think about myself
that I would have told him you know I I
wouldn't work that hard right so
basically what what they're measuring is
your ability to do math and your
willingness to invest effort in the test
right
we wanted to test how important is this
second ingredient your willingness to
actually your intrinsic motivation to do
well if you like
so what we did we took kids we didn't
tell them what what we're going to have
kids in in the U.S kids in Shanghai like
I said number 35 versus number one
in one case we just gave them a test we
saw similar differences as in the Pisa
then we we pay them for Success so for
every question that they got right they
got paid
now we saw that the Chinese student
didn't do better because they were
probably already at the top
no matter how much you'll pay me to to
do well in the SAT I have a limit that I
cannot do better than that probably
that's what happened to her the American
Kids on the other really improved
they really they did significantly
better when you paid them which showed
that it wasn't justability if you don't
know if you sit down in Italian I'll pay
you more if you'll be successful if you
don't know the math you can't do better
if I'll take you and ask you to fill up
the some tests in Hebrew no matter how
much I'll pay you you you're going to
fail right
apparently they knew the material well
enough that when we paid them they
improved drastically so the U.S kids for
some reason if you just ask him to do it
didn't invest you can think about
culture maybe in China it's more of a
collective culture in which if I ask you
to to work hard on this you'll work hard
on it even if you don't get individually
rewarded for it whereas in the US it's
not like that so
the diagnostic aspect of this is we
thought it is just ability or people
thought the teacher stability we should
know it's ability plus your willingness
to invest effort and ruthless American
capitalism that's that's what it was you
want me to work pay me precisely what's
the pay to quit strategy
I love this one so I teach negotiation
and I tell my students that no matter
what they shouldn't lie in negotiation
it's bad for ethical reasons it's bad
for your reputation just don't lie
with one exception the one exception is
that when you apply for a job
even if you're not excited you should
pretend that you're excited so imagine
that I would come to your podcast and I
said ah I really want to to take a nap
now okay ask me your questions no I need
I need to pretend that I'm excited I'm
really excited but I need to pretend if
not right because otherwise the podcast
is going to be much more boring
and the same is true for the job if you
are going to if you're looking for a job
and you say well idea I'm really
disappointed that that's where I landed
but you know I have no other options
I'll come over then I don't want to I
want only people that are excited
because otherwise they're not going to
do the job well
right so if I'll just ask you say that
you work for me and ask you are you
happy
you'll say yes because otherwise I will
fire you or something but I can devise a
way that will be what we call incentive
compatible for you to tell the truth so
I can find a way to use incentives to
get the truth out of you and the way is
by offering you this pay to quit say
that I offer you you know what if you'll
quit I'll pay you ten thousand dollars
no screen I'm not going to upset with
you I want you to stay but if you want
to leave
here's ten thousand dollars let's depart
his friends and you can go now if you
are you know on the margin you want to
leave but you're waiting you'll take
this 10 000 you leave us you're not
going to bed mouth us so you don't have
to suffer through firing you everyone is
going to be happy I lost ten thousand
dollars but I gained something that a
person didn't want to work here is not
working here and
the people that stay first of all I know
that they're really motivated otherwise
they wouldn't be here and second they'll
have to convince themselves now that
they're not stupid that what they did
was not a mistake it was a mistake if if
they would have taken the ten thousand
dollars
they would be better off if they decide
to stay they really need to justify why
it wasn't a mistake to take the ten
thousand dollars right so they're going
to work harder to to convince themselves
that that was a good idea otherwise why
would they stay
um there's a little bit of a sort of
continuity bias of subcost fallacy of
opportunity cost or pushing people
forward once okay we've passed this
threshold I need to make sure okay so
you mentioned that that you do you teach
negotiation yes
what what do most people who've never
studied negotiation get wrong
about negotiation
there are many things one of them so you
have a large group of people who just
don't negotiate and it's surprising what
is negotiable right as long as you do it
in a in a sensible way
many things are negotiable so it could
be when you check into the hotel you can
start and you can try and negotiate a
better room you might be surprised you
know what what you can get or when you
rent a car and it's true later on so
many people just accept what is offered
to them or not except decide not to take
it instead of trying to negotiate them
so if there is one thing that my
students take out of the class if the
one thing that they take after class is
now they enjoy how to negotiate that's
already a lot the second thing is like
we said about Mr about creativity and
failing
debrief what happened so think about
what happened why did it happen how can
I do better in the future
so after each negotiation try to debrief
with yourself try to learn from your own
experience that's also something really
useful that you can take out that people
don't do
what is your
favorite
strategy from negotiating that uh seems
to convert incredibly well whether it's
a framing of how you say something
whether it's a way to Broach a
particular topic is there something that
you think is a long lever when it comes
to negotiating
so one one that pops to mind is imagine
that we both we are going to negotiate
something you're trying to sell me a car
you're working a dealership you're
trying to send me a car but you're stuck
with only yellow cars
right
or you need to get rid of as many yellow
cars as you can and I'm coming to buy a
car from you
now in one case you can tell me you know
what if you'll buy a yellow car I'll
give you a discount
now I might say no way I don't want a
yellow car I might say sure I'll
do this or I might say actually oh great
I also want a yellow car that would be a
mistake by me so if you're telling me
I'll give you a discount if you have a
yellow car I should tell you I shouldn't
lie to you but I should tell you okay
you want this yellow to sell me yellow
car let's see what else you can give me
in order for me to to take it right so
in many cases we go into this that
either we that likely we want something
different and we'll need to compromise
somehow in many cases we want the same
and if we want the same I should let you
speak first to tell me about your
preferences and then I shouldn't say oh
great that's exactly what I want but I
should say look okay if that's what you
want we can we can I can work with this
let's see how right so try and get
something out of you by doing this
without lying but without revealing the
information that we want the same thing
one of my friends that I spent last
weekend with in Las Vegas has a method
of negotiating that he uses on his wife
when he wants to go to a particular
restaurant so give me give me your
thoughts on how effective this is so
let's say that he wants to go to uh
Cheesecake Factory uh so he that's his
desire he doesn't know what she wants to
do for the evening as opposed to saying
I would like to go to Cheesecake Factory
this evening or where do you want to go
for dinner tonight what he'll say is
would you be opposed to going to
Cheesecake Factory and she's not gonna
say like I'm not I'm not opposed to
going to Cheesecake Factory maybe there
are places that I would prefer to go
ahead of that he said well look I would
quite like to go to Cheesecake Factory
and if you are not opposed to going to
Cheesecake Factory that seems like we've
got a pretty good setup here uh
unfortunately now that he's talked about
it on a podcast she's become wise to the
trick that he was playing on her so I
think that he has sacrificed his
restaurant choice for the good of
everybody else but uh yeah that's his
that's his negotiation tactic so a few
thoughts about this first of all you
need to find friends that don't want to
go to The Cheesecake Factory come on
you're not 22 anymore you know it's such
a great podcast and at the last moment
we had to fall out about Cheesecake
Factory it's an elite establishment
um okay I
okay but
um so so a serious one and the joking
one so we're at the serious thing about
this imagine that you go with that I go
with my wife to a restaurant in the
movie
so one way is to find a compromise that
will go I want the Cheesecake Factory
she wants say a sushi place and we end
up in Italian place
and with the movie I want the movie with
lots of blood people killing each other
she wants lots of romantic and we end up
in the middle that's a mistake the right
thing to do is to find what she cares
about more and what I care about more so
it might be that I really care about the
restaurant and she really cares about
the movie so compromising is not
necessarily you shouldn't compromise on
each one of the items that you have
right so and find what who cares more
about what and then try to compromise
this way and then the real answer is you
know I'm with my wife for 34 years now
just do whatever she wants that's the
that's the easiest thing to to do when
you're talking about worldly wisdom I
think that that is absolutely perfect
urine easy ladies and gentlemen if
people want to check out the work that
you do where should they go
so my website has all the all the
academic work that I have and if people
want I'm always happy to to get emails
from readers that are interested in some
other things and start a conversation
mixed signals will be linked in the show
notes below I very much appreciate it
it's super super easy and accessible to
read I think I love the fact that you
integrated flowcharts you put drawings
in there and illustrations and stuff
it's really really good and uh today is
the day that the book launches so
congratulations I know that you've been
working hard on it thank you it was lots
of fun what's happening people thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
foreign